c'est quoi l'ancienne ce sont tous ces
bébés tant attendus qui ont rejoint le
ciel peu après ou avant la naissance
depuis maintenant deux ans l'association
porte assistance aux parents qui vivent
un tel drame qu'il soit récent ou bien
ancien
la mort du bébé de Leslie est survenu
pendant la césarienne une grossesse
s'ennuage arrivé à terme puis le
cauchemar
j'ai vécu le deuil pèlerinata en avril
2011 donc le 18 avril
alors que je m'attendais à donner
naissance à mon petit garçon Ethan
j'avais pratiquement 40 semaines de
grossesse quand je perdais l'enfant que
j'attendais l'unique enfant d'ailleurs
que j'ai eu à partir de ce moment je
j'étais consciente que je vivais quelque
chose de
d'inhumain et pour autant
un processus s'est mis en place une
résilience
qui fait que pendant 10 ans je n'ai pas
réalisé que je n'avais jamais fait le
deuil de cet enfant perdu
cet être que j'avais toujours dans le
cœur
tous les jours je pense à lui et pour
autant le deuil n'était pas fait un Noël
une amie lui rend visite avec les amis
de l'association commence alors pour
Leslie les groupes de paroles avec des
aidants formés à l'écoute et les
rencontres avec d'autres femmes
j'ai pu
sortir en fait de mon de cette
résilience qui était totalement ancrée
en moi j'ai pu enfin pleurer
là j'ai des cris
fais en sorte parce que la colère
n'était pas n'était pas ressorti
j'ai pu
mettre en lumière ce que j'avais vécu
pour pouvoir
par exemple des fermes mon trousseau de
maternité au bout de 10 ans je mon petit
sac de maternité celui avec lequel on
part pour l'accouchement de son
nouveau-né je ne l'avais toujours pas
d'effet autour du cercle aujourd'hui
d'autres parents sage-femme psychologues
venus partager leurs expériences dans
ces groupes de paroles s'exprime
tristesse ou colère sentiment de
dévalorisation ou culpabilité mais les
espoirs aussi c'est une réelle
satisfaction de voir des personnes qui
recommence à sourire j'aurais aimé qu'à
l'époque puisque j'ai été moi-même
victime d'auto-épirine natale qui a eu
une association comme celle-ci parce que
quand ça arrive bah on n'est pas préparé
dans la mesure où on s'attend un
événement qui est heureux et en réalité
ben voilà il y a tout qui vrille on a
préparé la chambre on a acheté les
habits etc et j'aurais aimé avoir ce
cocon ou me retrouver ou exprimer ce que
je ressens puis savoir quoi faire parce
que en termes de démarche en termes de
qu'est-ce qu'il y a à faire on ne sait
pas un peu perdu dans la mesure où on
est submergé par les émotions des frères
et sœurs aux grands-parents tout
l'entourage subit le deuil et lorsque la
parole se libère c'est toute la famille
qui guérit
c'est important mais qu'elle a parole
soit libérée autour de ce deuil et que
cette ceudeuil et cet enfant est induit
puisse être parlé puisse être évoqué
dans les condensations dans la famille
souvent ça n'est pas le cas souvent ça
n'est pas le cas souvent ça peut être
tabou pour les enfants qui sont déjà là
pour les enfants à venir pouvoir en fait
parler de ce frère ou de cette sœur en
fait qui est partie et est important en
fait ça fait partie de leur histoire
c'est toi l'ancienne reçoit les familles
quartier dit l'ont un fort de France un
numéro vert est à disposition le 080 79
11 22